[Music]
How many laps does that stone cost 2 million yen
How many hours should the company work
?  It
's been a long time. I'll be on stage. Belgium
is good.
[Music] The
Toru family,
that monkey
.
The weight of the chair that will be used is that the weight of Acha Hisama really lets
you eat Pann, and
here is JG -sama's Ijiwaru Ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh.
I
hope you're safe and above all, you're a princess, and the cash register seems to be doing well
.
Now I'm calling myself Dojima, and
I didn't even think about standing out.
I was able to find it,
so I don't think someone like a princess would be weakened just by losing a magic stone.